nous ne pouvons pas tolérer la violence
dans les années soixante dix la france
connaît des vagues de violences lors des
manifestations pillage vitrines brisées
forces de l'ordre attaquer les casseurs
de l'époque sont alors appelés les
autonome casqués et masqués et équipés
de barres de fer ou de tesson duteil
éléments incontrôlés casseurs anarchiste
intellectuelle petits enfants de mai 68
on trouve de tout chez les autos moan
sauf une organisation des reportages
sont consacrés à ce mouvement
décrit par certains journalistes comme
marginaux par d'autres comme un
mouvement d'ultragauche
mais les partisans du mouvement autonome
se définissent eux-mêmes comme ici en
ce sont des gens qui sont unis par une
chose c'est la lutte contre l'êta et une
hutte précises contre l'état c'est la
lutte contre les institutions étatiques
face aux dommages répété le ministre de
la justice brandi la menace de la loi
anti casseurs une loi votée en 1970 nous
ne pouvons pas tolérer la violence et
surtout la violence pour la violence et
à des faits de violence gratuite sauvage
qui consiste à casser à piller et à se
battre contre des gardiens de la paix
contre des agents de la force publique
qui sont destinés à assurer la sécurité
des français
alors nous allons faire appel à deux
procédures légales
premièrement la loi anti casseurs et
deuxièmement la procédure de flagrant
délit
mais la menace n'a aucun effet les
manifestations ont toujours leur lot de
casseurs comme en mars 1979
le ministère de l'intérieur avait attiré
l'attention des responsables de la cgt
sur les dangers que faisait courir à
l'ordre public
une manifestation d'une telle ampleur
non pas en raison de la manifestation
elle même mais à cause des violences
systématiquement provoquée par les
autonome et autres casseurs qui déborde
toutes les manifestations impossible de
savoir combien de personnes constitué ce
mouvement
man était maire qui connaîtra son pic
entre 1977 et 1979
mais qui périclitera au début des années
80 organisations flou violence pour
certains historiens les autonomes d'hier
serait comparable au black blocks
d'aujourd'hui
[Musique]